Joy Behar just raised this question on
The View I don't understand why people
go for the for the it's like police
sometimes when they shoot somebody it's
like can't you shoot them in the leg why
do you have to shoot
that's a detective you used to tell me
when he hears that on TV his eyes roll
because you have to shoot when you're
trained with a weapon for the mass of
the body so to shoot a leg or a wrist
happens in a James Bond film but in real
life that's actually not something that
they can do why because it's hard enough
to hit a Target so when you're shot you
you target practice on a mass which is
the main part of your body your torso so
if it's hard to hit a Target why do
these gun toters want us to constantly
have guns when we're not trained to even
shoot as well as a police officer she
tries to save her stupid questions well
then why does any why do they want us to
have guns if we're completely untrained
I don't want you to have a gun if you
don't know how to use